alright we're going to get started folks
thanks for coming out and braving the
weather that I think this is actually an
extraordinary turn out considering that
despite this being a fairly modest
snowstorm they're canceling schools and
closing shops and so forth so I don't
think anybody was prepared so maybe
you're here because you weren't prepared
for the snow d just did know how to
change your schedules but uh but in any
case I thank you for coming I want to
thank a few people before we get started
Suzanne install who isn't here but but
helped to arrange this and and is doing
this at the same time she's doing all
the heavy lifting on the big conference
that's happening this weekend professor
kaisers conference is happening this
weekend so if you don't already know
about that I suggest you you come and
ask a question or talk to Professor
Keizer or a number of other people here
who know what the conference because
it's going to be great and you
definitely want to go so this um this is
the i guess the third now in our series
of climate policy presentations this
semester we're co-sponsoring this where
the way josh galperin i'm the associate
director of the Center for Environmental
Law and Policy in our last at our last
presentation Bruce to the introduction
and forgot to introduce himself so now
I'm looking over here remembering that I
should probably introduce myself this is
Bruce ho he's the environmental law and
policy fellow at the Center for
Environmental Law and Policy and that's
a few other titles associated with the
law school but I don't know them so this
is this is the third event in a series
we have one more event coming up after
this on December 4th we're going to have
Heidi binko who is a vice president at
the Rockefeller family fund and she
oversees their climate climate funding
and their climate program so that should
be really interesting but first we've
got today's program now we had intended
this this to be a conversation about
regional perspectives on addressing
climate change in regions where climate
change is not a very salient political
issue and the two regions Wade selected
where the midwest and the south east to
places where there are active groups
working on addressing climate policy and
climate change issues but they're doing
it in ways that are distinct from the
ways that groups are working in say New
England or California unfortunately
possibly because of the snow possibly
for other reasons the south eastern side
of this
equation didn't make it tonight so Steve
Smith who is from the southern Alliance
for clean energy is not able to be here
but we do have Dorothy Barnett i'm going
to give Dorothy a quick introduction and
let her talk more about herself in any
of you came and really wanted to know
about what's going on in the southeast
you're not gonna get a presentation
about that tonight but I actually worked
for Steve Samantha work for the southern
Alliance for clean energy for for
several years so as we get into sort of
the question and answer session I'm
happy to try and answer some questions
and sort of fill that voice even though
I'm obviously not the ideal voice for
the southeast of the United States I may
be able to feel a little bit of that gap
but we're going to have a really good
discussion about what's going on in the
Midwest which has many of the similar
problems so this is Dorothy Barnett
Dorothy is the executive director of the
climate energy project based in Kansas
Lawrence Kansas I think although doing
work more broadly in the region
Dorothy's relatively new is the
executive director but has been with the
climate energy project for a few years
she's worked on the heart program which
I believe is the heartland area Alliance
Alliance for regional transmission so
has worked on the transmission side of
energy it does a lot of work on wind
power so the generation side of energy
and is one of the V or one of the
co-creators of the UM take charge
challenge which is an energy efficiency
challenge for municipalities and now
also for commercial and industrial
entities so you'll hear more about all
of this the one other thing I learned
though about Dorothy that I should
mention is that you went to a friend's
university I went to a friend's high
school this is a Quaker school so we
have that in common I didn't I did not
know there was a Quaker universities in
in Wichita came and so it's not just
University of Pennsylvania there's also
friends university so without further
ado I'm going to let Dorothy get started
and she's gonna give us a brief
presentation I've got some questions so
we're going to sort of try to do a
discussion that way I would have asked
them the two people but now will be a
little briefer and then we'll have
plenty of time for questions from
everybody else because we're half of
half of the time we expected to take
care so thank you and Dorothy take it
away thank you so much for braving the
snow and we're actually thrilled to see
snow in Kansas last summer earned last
winter we had men and for the first time
in number of you
or so so thank you I'm going to show you
a short video clip and to give some
context about the work that we do in
Kansas and throughout the heartland and
we were actually fortunate lawrence
berkeley lab's came to kansas last
summer into the short documentary about
our work and so this is a couple of
people that i just wanted you to hear
from a lot of talk about global warming
and to be honest with you I almost think
that it can be counterproductive because
the phrase global warming brings out so
much passion in two different side not
totally stroll along the fact that
fossil fuels are actually causing global
warming I think that's up to debate
however I do believe that there is
actual actual climate change going on
I'm just I believe that not actually
occurs naturally our perspective is not
so much worrying about whether man
causes global warming but more a matter
of why don't we just make improvements
that make sense economically because
there's so many of those types of
improvements that can be made let's
address the things that are easy to
address first make environmental
improvements that make sense
economically for the frugal mining
Kansans that we are and so again thank
you for inviting me today I'm here today
to share hope from the heartland and
evidence that a clean energy future in
the United States is achievable in spite
of politics or believe in climate change
you might think how do I know because in
five short years since a climate and
energy project has been in existence
we've been able to prove our theory what
we call Plan B actually works we went
from having prominent legislators
decrying wind energy as a pipe dream on
the House floor and to those same
individuals now calling it a critical
part of our energy mix and the fastest
growing segment of our economy and when
i started with cep there were about 64
megawatts of wind in
Kansas and at the end of this year we'll
have over 3,000 so I've seen quite a
substantial increase in two short ears
22 Kansas communities with populations
from a thousand to a hundred thousand
save 28 million kilowatt hours of
electricity in those same 22 communities
volunteers gave more than 5,000 hours of
their precious time to help their
neighbors save energy because energy
efficiency as you all know the least
sexy and most important of our energy
strategies has found devotees across the
state from city managers school
superintendents and Chamber of Commerce
presidents farmers ranchers priests and
pastors all of them pursuing energy
efficiency for their own reasons on
their own terms and influencing many
others to do the same put differently
our mission is to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions in real time and our means of
doing so is building the foundation and
the political will we believe for better
policy great organizations all seem to
have a great founding story and ours is
no different imagine it's Thanksgiving
and you are at your in-laws house not
your parents house for Thanksgiving but
your in-laws now imagine that your
father-in-law is a hardcore
environmentalist with an international
reputation for activism he's discussing
with you debating really why with all
the data with all the information and
science and the news coverage and Al
Gore's PowerPoint people in the
heartland still don't believe in climate
change why are there still climate
deniers and why aren't people changing
their practices they just don't get it
you make a simple assertion we need to
provide viable alternatives that are
cost-effective and immediately available
we need to show and actually demonstrate
a better future
early in 2007 our founder Nancy Jackson
met with Rick Reed of the Garfield
foundation and he shared a concern with
her that the u.s. could somehow manage
to pass climate legislation but failed
to nurture a durable will to implement
it so for those of you who aren't new to
this think about 2007 and where we were
in terms of the hope for cap and trade
or for a renewable energy standard at
the federal level there were lots of
ideas that that perhaps we could pass
climate legislation we were concerned
that he was concerned that states might
ignore the mandates and financial
mechanisms like a carbon tax might fall
prey to economic downturns and repeal or
suspension dooming the dependable
emission reductions we were counting on
and who is fairly insightful in 2007 and
based with the circumstances that we see
now Nancy's instincts and then told her
and our focus groups and polls later
confirmed that there simply was not a
demand for climate legislation in the
heartland so the question for us was how
do we build durable support and some
people team seemed to think that the
path to better policy and social change
is information most of us in this room
are susceptible facts changed our minds
so more facts better analysis proper
framing and enough press attention
should persuade the nation to act we all
know that there's plenty of data there's
plenty of modeling there's plenty of
smart framing on climate change however
even before the climate counter-movement
public opinion among conservatives in
the heartland was headed the wrong way
surveys consistently show near Kingston
near unanimous skepticism about climate
change in the tea party ranks I'm sure
you all saw the recent front line and
climate of doubt documentary and in that
Americans for Prosperity said we believe
we won the debate in the heartland and
that the debate is over on man-made
global warming when I started this
presentation I showed you a video
smart passionate Kansans care about
their state they care about their
country but they're questioning climate
change for s in our region climate
change is is politically polarized it
was seen it that early and increasingly
as a liberal issue as an environmental
issue and people in the heartland do not
consider themselves either liberal or
environmentalist so clearly plan a
didn't work for us in the heartland so
how do we find common ground so I got my
notes in a long page and so Plan B we
built durable relationships based on
trust and common cause we worked really
hard to find out what mattered to
Kansans we talked to people we worked
with them it wasn't about reframing for
us it really was about providing
solutions based on our Heartland values
we work together to implement them we
celebrated the successes along the way
and it was really important to show and
the economic benefits that was critical
for us our skeptics don't trust models
they don't believe in jobs productions
and Missouri isn't called The Show Me
State for nothing we must be able to
prove out what we propose make energy
efficiency and renewable energy default
choices because they work because
they're cost-effective and because they
build resilient local economies so what
did we do in Kansas and we found little
purchase for energy efficiency standard
or for building codes with policymakers
back when we started and the to take
charge challenge in 2009 and we decided
we decided we would just start from
scratch and so we created a competition
and energy competition called the
take-charge challenge knowing that our
peers and would influence people much
better than we we decided to harness the
competitive spirit of Kansas communities
and count on peer pressure to work the
take-charge challenge is a community-led
competition designed to engage citizens
and conversations about energy
efficiency
the challenge encouraged homes and small
businesses to change their mindset of
efficiency as a sacrifice to we win I'm
happy to answer some questions about
that a little bit later but we've had
some really great success and saved a
lot of energy and as Josh mentioned
another area that we work in is hard to
the heartland alliance for regional
transmission we all know that eventually
fossil fuels will run out as they do
prices will rise we will come they will
become volatile Kansas has the second
best wind resource in the nation and but
wind isn't perfect there are two things
about it it's variable and and right now
we need new transmission lines to carry
our great Midwestern wind from the
heartland to the east and so we created
and what we call the heartland alliance
for regional transmission is a group of
non-traditional stakeholders mayors and
county commissioners and landowners and
economic development professionals all
coming together under a common cause of
supporting wind energy and bringing more
efficiency and to the planning processes
throughout our regional transmission
organization the Southwest power pool
and this group has come together for a
couple of years now and they've created
some materials and really based on what
their peers need to know about wind or
transmission or efficiency ways to get
involved in advocacy and this quarter
and into the rest of next year they'll
be starting their own outreach in their
own States and so we're really excited
about that process and the other thing
that we're working on really has to do
with climate change in big ways and the
drought has severely impacted
agriculture in our state and many others
and so we really wanted to make that
connection with agriculture to be able
to have them understand that there were
opportunities that we're perhaps being
missed but we needed to do that in a way
that wasn't putting climate change out
there in their face and so we have
created a pilot program on farm water
and energy efficiency and what we're
doing is we are with the help of a
in committee across the state and water
energy and agriculture we are having
them identify innovation on farms in
saving water and saving energy and then
we're going to be highlighting those
folks as leaders in an opportunity for
others to emulate them i'm looking
forward to visiting with josh about his
questions and about your questions and
what I really you know would like to say
is that that from our perspective it
really doesn't have to be about climate
change and we've managed to build some
relationships we've managed to reduce
the emissions in real time and we are
hopeful to be able to continue this
important work so thank you thank you
well I want to start with a question it
doesn't directly address anything that
was up in your presentation but I think
it's probably on everybody's mind which
is we had an election last night which
which could be make a big difference in
the future of climate so I guess how do
you see this election playing into the
work you do specifically in Kansas in
the Midwest and more generally how do
you think this changes the prospects for
her climate legislation or other action
and you know it's it I we were in New
York when the election comes we weren't
even in Kansas so I don't know what the
response from local papers are from from
the folks back there will be and you
know from our perspective we I'm
thrilled that president obama was
reelected from sieepiess perspective it
really doesn't matter because regardless
of who's in office what we found is it's
really the work on the ground that
matters and i will say that we've had
some success with our very conservative
very republican governor Sam Brownback
and when he was a senator brownback he
was one of two Democratic senators who
voted for an re s renewable energy
standard out of his committee and energy
environment committee
and as governor he's been good on energy
he frequently calls Kansas the Renewable
state that he wants Kansas to be the
Renewable estate he publicly supports
extending the production tax credit and
we actually kicked off the second round
of the take-charge challenge at the
governor's mansion it was the first
event he held in office you know I hope
we have climate legislation I think
that's the way to go but but really from
our perspective we work across party
lines so that I mean that to me is a is
a real remarkable coup to be able to get
somebody like sam Brownback working
affirmative Lee and cooperatively on
some fun he wouldn't put it this way of
course but on climate change on
addressing climate change so can you
just fill us in sort of on the on the
time on sort of the trends and how that
happened and what role sort of activists
or people in your position can play to
to make that happen sure sure um and I
will give all the credit in those first
three and a half years to our founder
Nancy Jackson in case you all didn't
recognize the name connotation west
jackson is Nancy's father in law and so
that was the debate going on at the EPPA
at the table and Wes in case you don't
know friends the Land Institute and in
salina kansas on perennial agriculture
and named one of the top 100 people ever
i think and so so so Nancy spent a lot
of time nurturing the relationship with
senator brownback and his staff and you
know we weren't certainly making
constant trips to DC but when he was in
Kansas we were normally in his office
handing him some information about the
economic value that wind energy could
bring to Kansas and we were utilizing
nrdc research and others to be able to
say you know here's what we're talking
about with jobs and and he was you know
appealing to that and we did we did host
a state fair booth the Kansas State Fair
we had a giant
wind turbine blade and we signed
postcards and we took 3,000 postcards
from Kansans to senator brownback and
Senator Roberts at that time in support
of the federal renewable energy standard
and and and and he listened he
understood that that was a good economic
viability for Kansas in terms of
efficiency and whatever you may know
about senator brownback he's a very
faithful man and for him conservation
and efficiency is the right thing to do
it's taking care of what God's given us
and if you check out our website you can
actually see a video where he says that
very thing so so we were able to nurture
those relationships and get Kansans
involved so have you had the similar
failures and trying to deal with
politicians I mean that's at such a good
story I wonder if there are things on
the flip side where you've approached
somebody and said we wanted we've got
this issue this energy issue and had
pushed back or just a complete brick
wall or anything like that unfortunately
we have and we have we have a my own
personal congressman in the city I live
in is trying to purposefully roll back
the production tax credit and for wind
energy so he lives in and he represents
the big first which many people would
say that big first District has the
richest opportunity of any in the nation
for wind production as in western Kansas
lots of flat land lots of landowners
wanted to lease up their land for wind
turbines and he also plays host to a
seaman's nacelle facility in his
district and and his perspective is that
the government should not be subsidizing
any energy and so we've had
conversations in private and and at town
hall meetings we've had advocates
members of our heartland alliance for
regional transmission really have dug
into the fossil fuel subsidies and have
done some comparisons for him
about some of those subsidies versus the
wind subsidies and he he told a group of
people at town hall meeting that and he
doesn't really put much faith in the
Congressional Budget Office numbers and
which were the numbers we were
presenting to him and so yeah it's hard
and it's difficult and what we see
though is very moderate or moderate
Republicans don't buy that argument and
so we think he won't last another two
years and and and what is the messaging
or the argument that the more moderate
voters do buy from it not necessarily
from a political perspective maybe that
from his angle but from your angle
thinking of the the projects you do like
take charge or heart what what is the
sort of messaging that you attach to
those things that people can buy into
that can make those successful you know
it really you know when we talk about
Heartland values it really is Heartland
values people in Kansas are much like
they are in lots of places yes they're
conservative but they think it's
important to conserve their natural
resources that matters to them and a lot
of the work we do our with farmers and
with landowners and and and they are the
quintessential and protectors in our
region of land they that's their
livelihood they want to do what is best
in that area and faith has been a big
has been a big deal one of the projects
that we started was an Kansas interfaith
Power and Light chapter in Kansas and
and and really that was churches all
over the all over the state and reaching
out and talking about creation care
talking about taking care of the earth
taking care of their fellow man and but
doing it in the context of their faith
and and and that was a really important
issue so so faith messages have been
have been important really jobs numbers
and have been a big deal and one of the
projects that we did when we were first
starting to explore opportunities for
wind energy and Kansas
and that really has been an economic
boon by the way in this year alone
there's been three billion dollars
invested in Kansas in wind energy that's
not kind of numbers you hear from very
many industries these days so but in the
early days we were looking at the supply
chain and and what opportunities there
would be not only for wind farms but
what there would be for equipment to be
built and and I mentioned than a Siemens
in a Cell facility and that brought 400
jobs to the community I live in and
which is a county of 60,000 people and
400 jobs in one fell swoop don't happen
very often unfortunately with the
potential repeal of the protection tax
credit there have been some substantial
layoffs in and so those messages are the
messages we use let me go back to the
faith messaging for a second because
this actually maybe is it a good
contrast with something that was
happening in the southeast which is that
that message and was a large part of
trying to get climate action or other
energy-related activism and it actually
ended up backfiring a little bit because
there was there are several interfaith
Power and Light groups in the southeast
end and they took up this mantle of
creation care and similar similar
faith-based talking points and got a lot
of pushback from more conservative faith
groups saying you're phonies you guys
are no good there was a some Unitarian
congregations involved in this and and
they said well Unitarians you know
you're that's that's not faith and it
was a it was a real controversy they
actually ended up turning off a lot of
more conservative congregations in this
particularly in Tennessee so I wonder if
you had that kind of tension or as it
worked out pretty well you know and we
didn't have that kind of tension and in
part I think because um we went straight
to the Catholics I mean I think that was
a big part of it and there was a bishop
in Kansas who really embraced wind
energy and he hosted several wind farm
tours with with priests across the
region
there were sisters in different
facilities that were engaged and there's
not a huge Unitarian population in
Kansas and so am I don't even know for
sure if there was one there might have
been one Unitarian Church on the list
but mostly they were Catholic and
Methodist an Episcopalian churches and
so we didn't have a lot of that push
back i will say with that caveat and
interfaith Power and Light was not my
project it was my former colleagues
project and we've sent and they have
since split off from climate and energy
project and they and have their own
director now and in their own
organization and it's interesting
because they've taken a slightly
separate path since they've split from
us and they are actually a little more
politically active than we ever were in
that in that realm and so and we'll see
how their first legislative session goes
and which is coming up in January so it
seems and I can be wrong about this so
correct me if I am that when you're
talking about the idea of creation care
for instance you set that up so that you
can talk more explicitly about climate
change but I'm getting the sense that
the bulk of your messaging is not
climate change messaging it's saving
money creating jobs etc so I guess the
question is are there other places in
your messaging where you actually do
talk specifically or explicitly about
climate change as opposed to the other
benefits of these this transition rarely
we rarely do and and some people will
say what a cop out but you it's it
closes a lot of doors I mean if you walk
into a room and you lead with climate
change in this environment that we're in
and people will not hear you they won't
work with you and we spent about six or
eight months last year trying to decide
whether or not to change our name when
we started it was okay to be the climate
and energy project that was an okay
thing to be and it turns some people off
and they hear that and they say oh
you're that enviro group and oh you're
that liberal group and so we've really
had to concentrate on building those
those relationships with people with our
utility partners and we call them
partners because if we're going to get
any work done in Kansas on efficiency we
have to have the utilities with us we're
a regulated state most of the states in
the heartland are and if you want to get
work done if you want better efficiency
programs in businesses and for for
residents you have to have the utilities
support or at least their cooperation
and so and so you know there's at least
three other reasons to do things then
than just climate change so you know we
certainly are very upfront about our
about Arfa leaf we're very upfront about
our why we do the work we do and but we
don't say and you need to do it for
climate change so something else that
maybe you don't want to talk about too
much you publicly is you have to avoid
climate change because it turns people
off um but what you're doing is
advocating for efficiency energy
efficiency additional wind power and and
what this is ultimately doing and the
reason it's ultimately benefiting or the
climate situation is because you're
reducing the reliance on coal power
which I know is still a huge problem in
Kansas like everywhere else so I guess
the question is how much do you then
talk about why wind or why efficiency
actually make this impact about actually
taking Cole off the grid how much of
that is part of your your messaging and
how do you manage to talk about creating
jobs on one side but sort of reducing
jobs on the other side um our
organization started in part because
they were trying to build a coal plant
in western Kansas and so you know the
idea initially was we've got to do
something about that coal plant and I
can say and I'll honestly that was
before my day I wasn't on board when
they were fighting the coal plant I came
just a little bit after that
it became apparent very quickly that in
our state you can't just be against
something to get work done you have to
be for something and so for us we were
for when we were for efficiency and we
let others and be the Bulldog on no coal
and and that's still a really stinging
issue love organizations and a lot of
people that Cole plan is not built in
western Kansas and it's it's still in
litigation and not with us we're not the
litigators but last year in the
legislature there was a fairly heart
attempt to repeal our renewable energy
standard a renewable portfolio standard
that we have in Kansas and and and it
was directly tied to you
environmentalist said if you got your
RPS you'd let us have the coal plant
that's not what was happened but that
was the perception and so um you know so
they're still there still in there still
tied but that's not a you know that's
not the role that we that we play are
there people in Kansas who are pro coal
and anti-wind or as it by and large
become pro wind across the board in that
region and in Kansas is a very Pro win
state I think at our last poles it was
about eighty seven percent were or for
wind energy and so yes what what most of
the time you will find is we're in all
of the above state I mean that's what
you'll hear almost everywhere you'll
hear it at the top and you'll hear it
from people on the street we're in all
of the above and people are starting to
get the message that there are bad
things about coal and but but it still
is not very prevalent and and most of
the time they think it is
a bunch of rhetoric that those liberal
environment vaio mentalist are making
out and so you've now said you've got
3,000 megawatts of wind online so that
way at the end of the year that's like
three big coal plants you didn't and how
many cool plants online in that same
time period to have an 800 so that's
good news it is it is it is um so let me
sort of expand to the region the Midwest
more broadly and and this may be a
question that you don't have a lot of
details for but you know it's a big
region and you guys are based in course
in Kansas but you do some work another
other parts of the region do you find
you have to tailor your messaging or
your strategies differently in different
parts of one state or throughout the
region as a whole or it's the same
messaging work largely across the whole
region and our messaging is pretty
consistent across the region and but
what we have found and that's where
heart the heartland alliance for
regional transmission comes in it really
is in our messaging that we go in to
other states with and people know us in
Kansas we've been there we're based
there and but in the other states and
around the region we're not as well
known and so and the work still needs to
be done there that's still our regional
transmission organization which is kind
of the boundaries that we that we put in
but it's but it's those stakeholders
from those states that are the
messengers and that's kind of the kind
of maybe the key takeaway is and you
know having those people on the ground
in their states is what matters and so
they're the ones that are talking about
the value of wind for their state or
they're the ones they're talking about
efficiency and how it might work in
their in their state and it sounds like
these non-traditional partnerships and
non-traditional spokespersons are a
great boon for for getting the message
out there without having the climate
energy project be at the front and
therefore be at risk of creating some
sort of political backlash so can you
tell us a little more about about heart
and about to take charge challenge and
how these partnerships work and how you
get them established in the first place
because it seems to me that that's a big
challenge convincing a utility or you
know a big employer that they should be
on board with this one thing and so so
when we started the the residential take
charge challenge it really was about
going to our utilities of the US and
that we had worked with on other
projects before and saying hey we have
this idea and you want to get your
efficiency programs out there we want to
get people to start talking and taking
advantage of energy efficiency can we
partner can we work together and it
helped that at that particular time we
weren't asking them for money it was it
was a project that we had already funded
and so so we weren't asking them for
money we're just asking for their time
and it was beneficial for them and those
utilities at that time in 2009 really
didn't have relationships with their
consumers and it was oh that horrible
utility and so this gave them an
opportunity to talk to people and it
gave us an opportunity to really make
them champions for energy efficiency and
our reason for doing that was very clear
we knew that we wanted to go to our
corporation commission and talk about
energy efficiency and it's awfully
difficult for utilities to be all year
long in the press in front of their
customers talking about how good the
take-charge challenge was how great
efficiency was and then go to the
Corporation Commission and say oh but
that's not a good idea so we had our
reasons for doing it they had their
reasons for joining but it worked very
well together and so so that was one way
and with the take-charge challenge and
you know we are expanding that challenge
and to a Heartland challenge and we're
changing it from just residential it's
going to be a business challenge and I
wish I could tell you how how well it's
going but we're just getting started and
we have commitments from the utility
partners and some big businesses in
Kansas and hallmark sprint and burns of
mcdonald and some others and that we are
going to have as model businesses
they've done a good job with efficiency
and so they're going to share their
knowledge and expertise and it's going
to be a business competition in four
states with eight cities
this time the utilities are on the hook
for a prize and so because we've had the
reputation with with the Kansas City
Power and Light and the West stars that
we've worked with in the past there are
spokespeople in other states and they're
able to say 20 GNE in Oklahoma yeah
they're pretty good group go ahead and
work with them you can trust them so are
the utilities the good guys are the bad
guys in in your region I think it varies
region to region up we'll see their
utilities and it depends on things like
rates or how many outages there are or
how quickly you can recover from an
outage you're obviously we've had some
some sort of back and forth the
utilities here lately I understand in
bridgeport they were throwing you know
rotten vegetables at line workers but um
so what is it like for you guys you know
it depends on who you ask but in Kansas
rates are low and eight and a half nine
cents a kilowatt hour so that we have
low rates and the utilities are
accessible and I you can see them you
can talk with them you can work with
them you don't always we don't always
see eye to eye on what they should be
getting rate recovery for or how much
but but we we are able to at least have
a dialogue and have conversations and
outages aren't going to have a ton I
mean in Kansas I mean they're pretty
fast about if there's a tornado that
takes out some lines are pretty fast
about getting us back on line of late
there's been some talk about about
decoupling and and that has gotten
people a little nervous and and they're
not as excited about that the utilities
are pushing back on that a little bit
would explain a little more about
decoupling that's common subject matter
so we're going to get into too much
detail so decoupling is divorcing and
the amount of energy that they use from
the rates and so utilities have a set
cost that they need to recover for their
lines or four different things
and decoupling is separating that from
how much energy they sell and so they'll
be allowed to spread out that fixed
costs and it's not based on what the
rate is and and and there's some pros
and cons for that some people think it's
a good thing some people think it's not
and that's kind of been the thing that
people have been talking about in more
detail particularly for the gas
companies and as you all know natural
gas prices have gone to very low and and
so our natural gas companies in Kansas
are having a hard time even recovering
their fixed costs because they're so low
and so that's kind of where the
decoupling conversations have kind of in
so it's not driven by energy efficiency
it is not at this point driven by energy
efficient to bed yes it is so I just
have a couple couple more questions then
I'll turn it over to the audience here
so you said it was okay at one point
five years ago to be the climate and
energy project and that's obviously
become a little more touchy I'm curious
about the sort of the discussion there
if you if you would tell us about that
and what why you decided to stick with
it and if you think that maybe in the
Nitra distant future will be okay to be
the climate energy project again and I
think there were two things at play in
the early days and I mean I don't think
we knew any better okay you know we
didn't really have a sense of how
difficult it was going to be to be the
climate and energy project when things
first got started in in recent days and
in Kansas we were able to develop
relationships enough and respected
people new s so it wasn't doors getting
[ __ ] in our face but as we started to
spread out and talk to new utility
partners or talk to new public utility
commissioners for that matter and that
name was a hindrance and we also were
going through kind of some internal
transition and so there was a lot of
talk about is their value in in
switching and we actually had chosen a
new name and a new identity and it was
energy progress and had a great tagline
jobs prosperity security and but we
really have built up some capital with
our climate and energy
name you saw some quotes from the New
York Times and when we first started the
take-charge challenge we had a
front-page story on the New York Times
that's a pretty big deal for a tiny
nonprofit from Kansas and we had some
some exposure from lawrence berkeley
lab's with some reports that they've
done with some documentaries and we
actually am on Earth Day this year some
of you may have seen may be familiar
with earth the operator's manual and
they do they have a three series
documentary the second in the series is
called energy quest USA and the
take-charge challenge is one of five
that's featured on that so we really
looked at that exposure and the capital
that we built up within our own state
and among our peer network across the
nation and really felt like there were
not the benefits to outweigh having to
rebrand and do all these things and
that's a good segue into my last
question which is about the funding
situation for a group like yours at is
it is it I mean it's always more
difficult than you'd like it to be
obviously ha is it harder being a small
group in Kansas then it might be being
in New England or do you find that you
stand out more where does your funding
largely come from regionally or you know
how does thats what is the landscape
they look like and when josh introduced
me he told you I was relatively new to
the executive director position I've
been doing it just about a year and
before that I was a director of energy
and transmission so I'm a little geeky
on the transmission and energy side and
I'm really just trying to get my feet
wet and wrap my mind around the
fundraising side and so and so most of
our funding is from private foundations
many of it from funders on the East
Coast and we get funds from surd now we
get funds from the Rockefeller Brothers
we get funds from new york community
trust one of our big funders is the
kresge foundation they fund our work in
the southwest power pool we have some
West Coast funding through the Energy
Foundation and we've had been the
recipient of a Department of Energy
grant through that was what started our
heart program
and so so it's kind of varied
unfortunately when lenders say we fund
the Midwest what they're really talking
about is they fund the Upper Midwest
anything from Nebraska North and so
Kansas down is kind of a black hole for
funders and when when they when they
want to fund regionally it's usually
Upper Midwest and it has gotten more
difficult in the last few years to raise
funds for the work that we're doing and
the funders seem to appreciate the work
we're doing they seem to understand it
but many of our funders are starting to
make a shift from policy to adaptation
and they're starting to be most most
concerned with how do we help urban
areas when climate change happens and
when those effects impact them so so
that's that's that's the funding that
there but they want to fund that's what
they want to do and our assertion is
that if you don't have the Midwest where
were the highest emitter swear we have
the greatest opportunity for renewables
you lose you need us and so that's the
message that we try to put forth to our
funders and it's a challenge every day
and so tell them the sam Brownback story
and I have told the sam Brownback story
a lot and they're very healthy that
we're able to make those strides but
they're not opening their checkbook for
that so so it is difficult it is okay
well thank you very much so I want to
turn it over there are other questions
here
the wind industry we do not allow
visitors try and do that considering
that you're basically helping them and
you know we have partnered with a whea
the American Wind Energy Association for
wind belt tours so things like when
we've gone to different cities to talk
about wind we've let them funds at work
and we really have a policy to not take
industry money we also don't take money
from the utilities now we'll let the
utilities fund the prize to their
businesses for the competition but that
money is not going to ask so no we don't
get money from the wind industry and
given the circumstances that many of
them are in with the production tax
credit i'm not sure that they would have
a whole lot to give at this point but
but at this point that's we don't I hope
that we won't help to extreme weather
that's your occluding the drought does
that do some of your work for you
without having to use the words climate
change it does huh it does some and
we're hopeful that our on-farm water and
energy efficiency pilot is going to get
some traction and at least open the
doors for dialogue and to be able to
talk about why it's happening and but
but in our region you at least have to
first start the conversation somewhere
and part of our work with that will be
to look at some policies across the
state water policies energy policies and
our hope is that we'll be able to
connect some dots for people in a way
that isn't and in-your-face overt and
we've had some success with those types
of kind of policy down and and
grassroots up work before so so that's
what we're going to kind of try to do
here one of the things I found most
interesting about just a few slides that
you showed was I think those are quote
from the New York Times saying how it's
become a part of the cultural identity
of the heartland to be you know not
believing in climate change or something
like that and so and then you also
talked a little bit about how it's most
effective to have people on the ground
in the states from those states working
on this stuff so I was just wondering
just a sort of Frank just phrase that as
a question how important to your model
into your excess success is it that
these are Kansans helping Kansas or
Wisconsin's helping Wisconsin's and also
would people shut off if it were you
know even from the Northeast over from
the West it's really important I mean
that's that's kind of been key and in
the take-charge challenge one of the
things I didn't talk about was and we
didn't swoop in as an organization into
these sixteen cities and say yay let's
do energy efficiency we got together a
leadership team and it was the mayor and
it was a county commissioner and it was
the school superintendent and the coach
that everybody loved and the chamber and
they were the ones that were planning
the strategy for that community we were
there to provide assistance we had some
part-time staff who was helping to
organize meetings and events but really
it was all about what worked for them
and so that I think was key to the
success of the take-charge challenge and
we're doing that in the in the business
challenge now and you know it's those
model businesses it's the utility it's
the Chamber's it's the sustainability
organizations whatever they might be and
were the sustainability coordinators in
those communities but it's their project
and so getting them to have that buy-in
and I think has been really successful
and with the heartland alliance for
regional transmission you know it's such
a varied and diverse group you know
landowners are there for one reason the
economic development professionals are
there for another reason the clean
energy advocates are there for another
reason but ultimately they all want the
same thing for whatever reason and so
and having them in each of their
networks be more educated and more
interested in an active we think is what
will be most successful and they are
just starting their their state outreach
and I can tell you we took think there
were 27 and stakeholders to a Southwest
power pool board meeting and we had a
face-to-face meeting
then the next day was the Southwest
powerful board meeting they wanted to go
they wanted to see what it was like and
I got to tell you you walked in there
with this big group of people and you
have to pass a microphone around the
room and everybody has to introduce
themselves and so every time somebody
said I'm with heart and with the
heartland alliance for regional
transmission you know people's heads
started to turn and their eyes got big
and they started saying who is this
group and what are they doing here and
what do they want and really I mean we
were just stakeholders that that were
interested in the process and it was so
foreign to them that a group of people
like this would volunteer their time to
come to a meeting and be engaged in that
process I think so much more of that
needs to happen all across all across
the country if we're going to make some
real change challenge we're going to
doing any benchmarking a little not as
much as we'd like to and we have a
really small staff as I mentioned and we
work with two consultants at two
part-time staff and me and we're working
in four states and so the benchmarking
is not what we what it needs to be and
we my newest hire has a background and
some of that information so she's
helping us to design a little bit but
I'd be thrilled to have any suggestions
you have on the best way to do that how
do you know
other questions we gave your contacts
about how much part of our stuckness
around climate change isn't because
there's conservatives or media
corporations but because people care
about it or know about it aren't active
partner Lee taking strides we're
changing their lives aren't coming
protests aren't turning out I mean Haven
it's very quiet on climate change and
there are a lot of people here a lot of
bad men polarizations that concern or
really have a change of behaviour much
people way of protesting on 350 in Haven
there's six people and it's really a
very quiet time culturally and so I
wonder how much the wordings be eternal
more than extern then the organization
don't care about sustainability medical
issues and really have discussions with
on boards and volunteers and members
about the crisis were facing because I
don't get the sense an organization is
that people are taking us seriously and
a part of thinking or like civil rights
movement people did free radical things
which la quinta da sky can be factored
that's crazy Mississippi will never turn
whatever but because of that was
inspiring actions that people were
motivated in some ways take risks and do
other things look at their own lives and
that's not happening to us right now in
any serious way so I know those
discussions at in Kansas reorganizations
and be with on lifestyles and if you
choices it's quite as momentum let me
see three bikers a day fighting right
even with all of our mental folks would
say words can we do this happen and in
the heart landed in kansas there are not
a lot of environmental organizations
period and not very many doing this work
and part of our hope with heart has been
to pull in some of those other voices
and we're starting to do that more and
we work with some folks from the Center
for Rural Affairs in Nebraska and
Oklahoma sustainability network in
Oklahoma Missouri energy efficiency
association in Missouri
but but collectively so much of the time
I think we're just trying to keep our
heads above water with our own programs
so part of our mission and goal is
trying to to reach out to those others
and we think that the challenge has
given people a reason to take some
action and we've seen that with things
that they're actually doing and changes
they're actually making in their homes
and you know for us you may be there has
to be a reason people have to have a
reason to do it because again they're
not going to just walk in and say I
think climate change is important and
and so so we've given them competition
as a reason to to make some changes but
but I agree I mean I think I think we're
kind of in this weird space where so
much money has been spent to to to you
know fill that that climate science void
or confusion and so trying to figure out
how you how you get out of that and we
think it's it's personal connections and
it's and its people two people talking
over the mailbox about things that they
need to do for whatever their reason
happens to be anybody else
that's for me I guess yeah well I think
the story is very much the same in the
southeast it it climate messaging
doesn't work but the southern Alliance
for clean energy the group that I worked
for and Steve Smith runs who would have
been here has sort of a s a bifurcated
strategy in the actual on the ground
practical programs that they carry out
they do very much similar things to
what's happening in Kansas there's a lot
of energy efficiency efforts that the
messaging is it saves you money it's a
cheap resource it's it's cheaper than
building a new nuclear reactor which is
what's happening in the southeast why
spend four to twenty billion dollars to
build a nuclear reactor when you can put
a couple million into energy efficiency
and get much better returns and actually
maybe get it done which isn't happening
for nuclear reactors so there's the
economic argument the economic argument
that when you build new generation
whether it's a nuclear reactor or a coal
plant that's going to raise rates and
people can talk about cole and nukes
being cheap but it still costs a lot of
money to build them and that's an
important thing to people to understand
so this kind of messaging goes on a lot
a lot in the actual programs but in the
outreach materials still actually has a
lot of talk about climate change in the
blog which is very active for the
southern Alliance for clean energy the
press release is things like this
climate actually is still very much part
of a message and I think that's a
vestige of the of the executive director
who he group he came came of age in a in
a very strong activism and and grew up
in a time where chaining yourself the
things was it was the way to get things
done and and so it's hard for him it's a
person to give up the very direct
messaging but but practically speaking
the work that's being done is very is
the messaging is is changing
dramatically so we fight coal plants not
because of their climate impacts but
because of their human health impacts
it's not about the it's not about the
carbon that's coming out it's about the
particular matter and the mercury and
the coal ash nuclear reactors it's
because they're expensive and
and they don't make sense to build and
renewable energy because it creates jobs
and it's a new opportunity for for
growth of new new new industries in the
southeast so I think it's very similar
we have had no luck down there with
politicians whatsoever and I think
that's because governor Brownback and
and others see that there is a there is
money cast money to be made in the wind
industry the southeast does not have the
same natural resources for this sort of
thing neither wind nor solar but the
southeast somebody is called the Midwest
the Saudi Arabia of wind and we we've
been calling the southeast the Saudi
Arabia of energy efficiency because
people have very low rates down there
some of the lowest in the country for
some of the state's Tennessee in
particular because of the Tennessee
Valley Authority but then these low
rates allow people to use extraordinary
amounts of electricity without being
concerned for their for their overall
bill but they could dramatically reduce
energy usage pay it's still a lot less
and and and there's just tons of space
for that for that kind of efficiency and
reduction in use except in the state of
Alabama which they they're constantly
told they have extraordinarily low rates
they actually have the third highest
rates in the entire country they have
the third I'm sorry excuse me the third
highest builds in the entire country
their rates are middle for the country
although they are high for the southeast
only Florida and Florida and maybe
Louisiana maybe have higher rates but
but they spend an extraordinary amount
on their bills that they're behind
Hawaii and I think New Jersey and their
actual what they pay in their actual
bills and the reason is because they're
largely being lied to by the utilities
about how little they're paying and they
keep saying to themselves now we're not
paying anything so there's a real
there's a real information gap and I
think that's true at energy in general
that's not need to the southeast but I
think as you say it's a cultural piece
of piece of this is cultural and there's
a lot of cultural pride in the southeast
about our electricity
we love Cole and that's why its chief we
don't have to worry about it and when
and people are unwilling to learn that
actually their electricity is not cheap
because of coal that it's been
increasing and they're actually paying a
lot more in their bills because they're
not willing to sort of take those next
steps but but I think the take-home
message is it's not that different it's
not that different we think the real
opportunities from the southwest power
pool and an area that we're working on
is in demand response and so lots of
opportunities there's lots and lots of
smart meters and happening in in the in
the heartland and so trying to engage
people at the Southwest power pool at
our transmission organization to think
about the rules that might impede and
demand response or energy efficiency and
ways to make those better and and so we
think there's a lot of opportunity for
that to that we're just really starting
to touch on where this is going
directions where the Congress
here to just just start to the traction
you really mean that content at this
point in time ah things are moving in
the right direction i think there's
there's definitely momentum 20 by 20 or
80 by when to 2050 Cole retirement is
happening at a very rapid rate in the
southeast at end of the Midwest and
across the country so there is
absolutely a possibility of that could
happen because Cole is coming off line
so quickly and is going to be replaced
one way or the other with something less
carbon-intensive wind efficiency solar
natural gas which obviously has its own
issues but but by and large is less
carbon-intensive so I think it's we're
moving very quickly in that direction
but I don't know how much coal is going
to come offline and then what happens
next because the economics are in favor
of coal shutting down but I don't know
if the economics are quite there yet for
that next more difficult step but
retiring coal 10 years ago seemed very
unlikely when President Bush was talking
about doubling the country's I bet the
number i don't think he wanted to double
it but dramatically increasing the
country's coal capacity and here we are
seeing it dramatically decrease so
things change well and you know you
heard me say when we started there were
64 megawatts of wind in Kansas at the
end of the shuo be over 3,000 and Kansas
actually gets almost eight percent of
our own electricity we generate from
wind and that puts us up in the top five
and so that's a big deal and you know we
think that there's been there has been a
lot of work done on the clean energy
transmission grid and kind of in some
thought processes and some planning and
if we're ever really going to reach
twenty percent or others there's got to
be some work on the transmission grid
and we've got to be able to do some
interconnections from the east to the
west and Texas and others and so and
change is happening what would speed it
up and is a federal renewable energy
standard if we could get at the federal
level for them to say here it is we're
doing this and you would see
exponential growth and so you saw a
basically senator based on work
happening that they put expect six
degrees Celsius increased by 2100 and
carbon assets we've stranded quotes that
cannot be business as usual this is a
report for business folks what climate
change it's a pretty strong amasai it's
not about politics it's just your mac
must impart intensive stuff be careful
right you're investing anything
interesting anything that relies on
weather patterns that are recognizable
and and water being available it's a
scary investment to make that kind of
the unfortunate financial dependence
that a lot of Midwestern farmers have on
large egg agro industries and things
like that and it seems to me like
leasing out farmland or wind production
could provide a little bit of financial
dependence for people so have you found
any one of those in any of those
corporations making their way sticking
their nose into your business or
provided resistance to your work or is
that not coming up not at this point and
there's there such a huge and there's
such huge support from landowners for
wind and it's really an opportunity for
them to diversify and so we haven't
gotten that where we get the pushback
and from agriculture as if we start
really putting climate change in their
face and I was telling Josh that three
years ago we hosted professor from
University of Tennessee and we put on a
forum how agriculture could thrive in a
low-carbon economy it was in February of
2009 we fully expected that that was the
direction we were going to go
and and we had all the commodity groups
there we had big AG we had small we had
landowners and it's very successful good
conversations about what direction they
could take and then it kind of just fell
off a cliff and so we've now just
started to try to make our way back into
the conversations with AG again about
about energy practices as it relates to
water because that's something that is
impacting them right now that they're
willing to talk about and but it's but
it's interesting you know we have Farm
Bureau and we have farmers union and we
have both of the presidents of those on
our steering committee that's a real
diverse group of conversation you know
what one thinks is good the other
doesn't really so trying to come to some
consensus and some common ground with
those groups has been interesting but at
this point we have not had pushed back
from from big egg
decision what do you think the future of
your nonprofit is um I think that if
federal renewable energy standard were
to be passed and we probably wouldn't
have to do much of anything on wind I
mean it's going to go it's going to go
forward and there's still a lot of work
to be done on efficiency and there's
still a lot of work to be done on demand
response people really don't think about
their energy use you know they don't
when we first started this work and we
were pulling Kansans to in doing some
focus groups a lot of people thought
most of our energy came from solar I
mean it's just not a not a not a talking
point I just they don't think about it
they don't talk about it which for me
and for my young daughter here who
listens to me talk about energy all of
the time it's hard to fathom but but
that's a reality it's cheap it's there
every day you flip on the light and it's
there so people don't really think about
energy use and so you know we think
there's always going to be a place for
people to talk about smart uses of
energy
energy efficiency and this applies item
the glorious when energy and do you find
it actually harder to promote energy
efficiency and do behavioral change
rather than be on let's get wind and
it's fabulous energy so I guess I think
there's a lot to begin from energy
efficiency but if it's hotter in terms
of infrastructure and and also
investment as well and it is difficult I
mean it's not it's not the sexy thing
and you can't see the jobs that are
created from it we have low rate so
people don't really you know they're not
going to save even if they save thirty
percent you know that's maybe a hundred
dollars a year so it's not you're not
talking about big dollars for people and
and so and we talked about it in the
context of fun competition and
encouraging people to do something good
for themselves for their neighbors help
their community win a prize that that's
been one way that we didn't we've
addressed it and you know I say that our
rates are low and they are comparatively
speaking but and they are going up and
so we are starting to try to have
conversations and our corporation
Commission's our Public Utility
Commission levels as the utilities are
going in to ask for retrofits of coal
plants and you know we're beginning to
intervene on policy to be able to ask
the question you know why aren't we
considering efficiency it's much lower
cost here's opportunities and you know
the issue with efficiency from a utility
perspective is it's got to be something
they can depend on and so they're
nervous about efficiency and using that
to meet the same type of load that they
could get otherwise from other sources
and so it's a balancing act and trying
to keep it in front of people and making
sure people don't have that Jimmy Carter
in a sweater I'm freezing you know
mantra and there's lots of things they
can do and still be comfortable so
that's that's been our message for
proficiency but it's harder than it is
with wind there's no doubt about it
okay well thank you guys very much for
coming